I think is just a liberal conservative
difference I don't think these
comprehensive constitutional theories
are worth the paper they're written on I
don't think there's any content to those
two originalism Act of Liberty any of
that stuff
it's liberals and conservatives the
example I like to give there's a Jewish
joke it's not I think to improper for
television so person and you know Minsk
or something or Pinsk is walking down
the street and he sees that the that the
moil so the moil is the person who in
traditional judaism performs rituals
circumcisions right on babies
so the moil has a an office place of
business and the this passerby notices
that in the the window of the Moyles
little shop is a display of pocket
watches and he walks in he says well
what what is going on you're displaying
pocket watches in your window and Europe
you're a moil you're not a do not a
seller of watches so the Moyles
responses what do you want me to exhibit
in my window right so that's my reaction
to these fancy theories about the
Constitution the judges are not going to
say well the reason that I am for
abortion against abortion rights or
something is I'm a liberal I'm a
conservative I'm Catholic or I'm a
secular Jew whatever it is they don't
say that right can't say that so instead
they construct some elaborate
rationalization but I really do that I
have a book coming out in the spring
called how judges think and I discuss
this issue of comprehensive
constitutional theories at
some length I discussed justice Breyers
book and I discussed no justice scalia's
and others views opposite views as you
as you mentioned and I don't think
there's anything in those I think these
guys have feelings no political feelings
moral feelings emotional feelings about
these cases and they dress up their
feelings in a you know in a elaborate
way one things that bothers me about the
judging business generally is that the
JA help on not guilty of this but the
judges tend to conceal in their opinions
and also often their public statements
what is actually important in a case
they they talk about history they talk
about the plain meaning of statutory
language but really it's not that it's
something more basic it's not always
basically political or anything like
that it may just be a sense that you
know this particularly this doesn't make
any sense going to produce too many
cases it's going to encourage socially
unproductive behavior and so on so so if
you go back one of the early sex cases
an antecedent of Roe versus Wade was at
case called Griswold versus Connecticut
in the early 1960s and the question was
the constitutionality of a of a
Connecticut law that forbade the sale of
contraceptives even to a married couple
and the Supreme Court hello isn't gun
constitutional and there's a lot of
talking various judicial opinions then
later commentary about you know right of
privacy and where is it in the
Constitution this or that all very
semantics well what the case came down
to it seems to me is that
the law was not the law was not enforced
in the sense that first of all condoms
because they also are you know
prophylactic as against venereal disease
could be freely sold so there's a huge
gap as the first thing but the major
consequence of the law was that you
couldn't have birth control clinics in
Connecticut because that was so obvious
flouting of the law that it would be it
would be enjoined or the operators
prosecuted on the other hand if you went
to a gynecologist he could prescribe you
know a diaphragm or something I would
know probably guess that what that meant
was that middle class people could get
whatever contraceptive assistance they
wanted but lower-class people who would
go to clinics but didn't have their own
gynecologist or anything they wouldn't
have access to any contraceptives except
condoms so that was the real injustice
of the law earth talk in those terms it
had it had a disproportionate effect on
poorer people I was wrong now that's the
essential point which is not made in any
of the judicial opinions now then the
question is is is the fact that this is
an offensive law what what how germane
is that are what one of the fact that
that the only reason for the laws is
that is the large Catholic population in
Connecticut because no one else this is
before the rise of evangelical Christian
and the evangelical Christian John
objector contraception objective
abortion only the Catholic Church as far
as I know among major religions believes
that contraception is wrong artificial
contraception supposed to you know the
rhythm method so so you have a law
that's you know really secretary are we
procured by a religious group for second
sectarian reason
and you have ended the law bears harshly
on the poor part of the population
though those are the essential and you
fit that into a constitute there's
nothing in the Constitution that seems
to bear on issues of that sort but you
can make a leap and say no concept of
Liberty in the due process clause 14th
amendment can encompass sexual livery
some dimension of sexual Liberty and
this is an unreasonable restraint you
could write an opinion like that which
we've been a lot more straightforward
than what not only the justices but you
know 40 odd years of commentary on this
case as has the terms in which it's
based